>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: Well, today
we're starting a wonderful series.
Profiles of remarkable
women from the Middle East,
from the Muslim world who have
achieved extraordinary things
in their lifetimes.
This project is done in
cooperation with the [inaudible]
and the Library of Congress.
And this afternoon we're
interviewing Najat Khelil,
one of the most remarkable
women that I have met.
A nuclear physicist, a woman
advocate, a peace maker,
and a delightful friend
and colleague.
Najat, I know that your
life has been full and rich.
Tell us something, where were
you born and how did you get
to become a nuclear physicist?
>> Najat Arafat Khelil: Well, I'll
try to make it as short as possible.
And thank you very much
for the introduction.
I don't know if I deserve it.
I was born in Nablus, and
you can tell I'm old enough
to have been born when
it was called Palestine.
So it says on my birth
certificate Nablus Palestine.
Then, you know, I grew up there,
of course, through high school.
And I happen to be among the first,
the top five in the national
high school examination.
You know, in Jordan they
have an examination just
like the baccalaureate where I was
among the top five in the country.
And I was awarded the
scholarship to go study.
And I happen to be really good
in math and sciences in school,
but I was interested in psychology.
So when I was given the scholarship,
they asked me what
do you want to study?
I said psychology.
They said no way.
You'll read it in your free time,
we want you to study mathematics
and physics so you
come back as a teacher.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: And
that was your parents?
>> Najat Arafat Khelil:
The government.
Because I was awarded the
scholarship from the government.
No, my parents, my father encouraged
us so much he really cared
so much for our education.
So I went to study
for undergraduate,
and I started physics.
And once I started, I enjoyed it.
And then.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb:
And that was there?
>> Najat Arafat Khelil: That
was in Cairo, Cairo University.
Then in 1962 I was awarded an
Fulbright Scholarship to go
to the United States and
to Ohio State University
where I continued with
a master's degree.
And at the time, you know,
everything was talking
about nuclear physics and
we were going into space.
It fascinated me, and I continued
then went to Texas and continued
for the PhD in nuclear physics.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: And that's where
you met your husband, isn't it?
>> Najat Arafat Khelil: I met my
husband five days after I arrived
in the United States at
Ohio State University.
So I always.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: And
he's also a man of science.
>> Najat Arafat Khelil:
He's a petroleum engineer.
He's a PhD in petroleum engineering.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: And the current
administer of energy in Algeria.
>> Najat Arafat Khelil: In Algeria.
So I always tell him, you
know, you never give me time
to really enjoy myself in America.
You know, you got me
five days after [laughs].
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: And then you
became very interested in women.
>> Najat Arafat Khelil:
Well, it happened,
you know, after a long while.
I graduated in 1973.
Actually, when I got my PhD in
Texas, I was the first woman
in the state of Texas to
get a PhD in this field.
So it was a big.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: A
big deal, of course.
>> Najat Arafat Khelil:
They wrote about me
in the newspapers at the time.
After that, so from '73 till
1982, that's when I shifted.
I was teaching at George
Washington University,
and then the situation became
really bad, you know, in Lebanon
and Palestine, the Middle East.
So I felt I needed to do something.
So I started being active, and we
established this organization there,
a women's council in 1982.
And then I started attending
conferences and going to seminars
and really having meetings.
So it occupied me so much that I
felt I have no time for teaching.
And that's when I quiz
teaching and became more active
in all women issues
and American issues.
That was a change.
And then I found also that
it's very interesting for me
and very important to do.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: Tell me
something about your organization.
Because it's a very important one,
and I know that you're doing
some exciting projects.
>> Najat Arafat Khelil: Well,
the Arab Women's Council
started in 1982.
And when we started, it was
really more political activism.
Then we shifted to have it more
for information and educational.
So currently our major agenda is
giving lectures at universities,
attending conferences and
participating in them just
to present the proper
image of the Arab woman
which is very much
misunderstood and misconstrued.
And it is very important for
us for the American public
to know how Arab women
are, their achievement,
and their capabilities,
and what they can do.
This is part of the work we do.
Another part which is also training
for Arab women in the Arab world.
And so far, we got two grants
from the state department
through the Office of
Education and Cultural Affairs
to do leadership training for women.
We had one done already in Syria
where first we had Syrian women come
to Washington and attend
two weeks of workshops
about leadership training, and
how to establish and organize
and strategize in a
non-governmental organization.
Then the second part was to go
to Syria and do the same program
for a larger number of women.
Now, we've been awarded recently a
grant to do the same work in Morocco
and Syria again and [inaudible].
And follow a program to do
it in Jordan [inaudible].
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: Wonderful.
>> Najat Arafat Khelil: So as
matter of fact, when we did the work
in Syria, when we went there, it
was the first time that a project
or a program was done
officially and right above board
between the Syrian government
and the United States Embassy.
The minister of labor and
public works in Syria came
and she opened the workshop
which was, you know,
for us it was really
amazing, you know.
It's just a plain workshop
for women.
But they give.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: The minister
gave it so much importance.
>> Najat Arafat Khelil: Yeah,
importance because it was the first
and the ambassador at the time,
the American ambassador to Syria.
And, I mean, they told
us they considered
like a groundbreaking
event that happened.
So that's why we're very
interested in this work.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: I wish
you, Najat, all the very best.
I know that you are
doing wonderful things
and that you will continue doing so,
and that you are promoting women's
image and helping women out.
And this is something which
is important to us all.
So thank you very much for being
with us today and giving
us your time.
I know you're leaving for
Osaka in a few minutes.
And so in the name of the
Library and Fulbright,
okay, we thank you very much.
>> Najat Arafat Khelil:
Oh, well very much
for giving me that chance, too.
And it's very important all the
work we're doing, all of us.
Thank you.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.